i don't believe in art okay like i
believe seventy percent of art is fraud
okay i don't know that it's fraud but i
don't i don't understand it so i'm with
you there but check this out so i so but
i'm but i'm so skeptical that i i did
research okay and we're sitting there
going through the stuff with art right
where today total value of art in the
world is 1.7 trillion dollars okay and
deloitte says that by 2026 it's gonna
increase by 900 billion dollars and
there's a place in switzerland called
geneva freeport that holds a hundred
billion dollars of art
1.2 million pieces they hold a hundred
billion dollars in one building you may
want to show this building that's the
building that building in geneva
freeport holds one point uh holds a
hundred billion dollars of art in that
one building okay
and this is people that buy the art that
send it there who never see the r to
prevent from paying the taxes and it's a
form of a vault so they don't buy it
because i'm gonna show it off at my
house they buy it as an investment
purpose they put it in a lot of times
what a lot of billionaires and
millionaires will do is they'll buy an
art at a half a million dollars they'll
send it there they'll get a new
appraisal to say it's worth 10 million
dollars and then they'll give that art
and donate to a museum and they get a 10
million dollar write-off where they get
to write off 30 of it so there's a lot
of different things with art but i'm
really trying to see maybe pat you want
to give the people in the art world a
break so even this uh salman mundi thing
that recently saw
not rushdie no no selma salvador dali
you can pull up the piece that the art
piece that sold for uh 450 million
dollars recently
the guy from saudi arabia that bought it
uh leonardo di bo what is it called uh
salvador mundo salvador mundi so this
thing in 1958
sold for 45 pounds
then in 2005 it sells for 2 000 that
sells for 10 000 in new orleans
then a person comes out and says this
was part of
you know the queen of england's
collection and it's a real piece of
leonardo and et cetera et cetera
next thing you know it sells for 450
million dollars by a person that nobody
knows about right so and then like
80 chance it's a fake and it's not real
so i really want to debate myself on
this i really want to
convince myself
that the cia and the fbi and these
organizations do a lot of good
where the net net positive you know it's
a net positive than a net negative i'm
okay with
i'm not looking for perfection right but
i want to be able to trust it but man
it's very very hard to do with the last
few years on what's happened my level of
skepticism is so high it's hard to
believe
how much good they do rather than how
much bad they do to the world uh i can
understand i can totally understand and
i don't i wouldn't disagree that i am
also disappointed with what i've seen
in the last uh since i left in 2014. so
what is that eight years um there's a
couple of things that are
you brought up two points right you
brought up your own uh questions about
the the productivity and the
constructive use of the intelligence
services and then you brought up the art
thing as i think as a parallel
this has a very interesting
story or a very interesting explanation
if you if we can get to it i think you'd
like it but when it comes to the value
of intelligence services
it's hard to assess the value when you
only see
the cost of goods sold right that's
essentially what you're looking at what
the american people look at with any
secret organization they only see what
they do wrong
they only see
the things they that costs money they
have no idea the lives that are saved
they have no idea the tragedy that's
avoided they don't get those stories i i
love jonah she's a she's a great a great
lady a great patriot a great cia officer
but she embellishes
sometimes what it's like to be a cia
that's an old school tactic we like to
over reach
in in our gray hairs always overreach
and i die and and uh
idolize what it's like to be cia part of
it's because that's how they were
conditioned while they were there
part of it's because they always want to
be pitching people back right the more
accurate the more accurate way of saying
it she was right about the curiosity and
she was right about the competition she
was right about all that but we
absolutely celebrate our victories we
just don't do it publicly
we have margarita machines inside cia
we'll shut down offices for half a day
we'll put them on skeleton cruise just
so we can celebrate the fact that we
just avoided a civil war in
india right absolutely those high fives
all the time people will sit in a
bullpen we have a bullpen not too
different from this and you'll sit
together with a few people overseas and
you'll be like holy [ __ ] guys i think we
just i think we just literally saved 10
american lives today we just brought
down a terrorist cell that no one even
knows existed without any specifics how
many times does that happen in your
seven year career when you were there in
my it happened probably three solid
times in my seven years it were it could
have been massively damaging to the
world where americans would have been
killed innocent americans would have
been killed there's a very clear example
of that there's a place where we would
probably be
10 to 15 years
behind where we are right now in terms
of the global economic situation between
china russia and the united states had
had one of our operations not happened
and then there was another one that was
in africa where it would have been like
innocent non-american lives but allied
lives western lives
british citizens canadian citizens a mix
just group that was targeted by a fringe
extremist group in africa so we have
those victories we celebrate those
victories we love those victories we
don't talk about those victories so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]